[Music]
today's episode is brought to you by
t-mobile America's best unlimited
network what's going on guys
Game of Thrones season 7 is nigh and
there's so many characters so many plot
points I forgot a lot of what happened
last season so that's why we do our
public service the idiots guide to Game
of Thrones and we've got an amazing crew
to break down the last season for us in
fact they are the hosts of screen
junkies show watching Thrones first I'd
like to introduce you know from SJ news
and all over the place
Roth Cornett hello I'm excited to get
our Thrones on oshio
was one of the previous hosts of
watching Thrones and she's emerged back
welcome back
Michelle Boyd thank you very much for
having me again of a raging throat her
right now he's the head writer of honest
trailers you know let me love them
Spencer Gilbert I drink and I know
things he'll so we're going to break
this down piece by piece to make sure
that you guys are all caught up and
ready for the premiere of season 7 rock
shall we venture to the north so the
season opens and after torturing us fans
letting us guess John stay with Jon Snow
is dead finally as predicted Melisandre
brings him back to life after the hessed
of stir Davos you were dead and know you
note it's completely mad so maybe he's
basically bulletproof for the rest of
the series he uses this opportunity to
basically get out of his own wellshe's
him didn't so yeah we learned a little
bit more about Melisandre she went from
red fox to Silver Fox or not quite a
Silver Fox she was yeah just a hack like
a hundred and ninety years old I do
think that she will come back because I
do think she has a larger role to play
and she's still a big believer in Jon
Snow if you return to the north
I have you Hyneman isn't matter there
was a nice brother-sister bastard sister
reunion it's the first episode you're
waiting for starts to get back together
and who is it it's Sansa and Jon who
actually didn't have that close of a
relationship but because it's everything
that they've been through it's kind of
trench mentality and now they're very
close accepted she's not fully trusting
Jon
she has an Alaia
with Littlefinger that she doesn't tell
him about meanwhile Littlefinger is
trying to convince her that he and she
together should take the Iron Throne -
by my side so fan-favorite Lyanna
Mormont comes out of nowhere to steal
our hearts and make us want to elect her
as president of the world and she's
altom utley able to get everyone
rallying behind John he's my king from
this day until his last day and they're
sort of like a sideways glance and
you're wondering is Littlefinger going
to be able to convince her to go to the
darkside fully now Ramsay has rekon of
course John being John tried safer God
which he cannot do Jon Snow in one of
the most amazing sequences of the season
- right in the middle of it
claustrophobic so it's this amazing
battle speak with you and it looks like
all is lost and lo and behold the nice
lavell come to save the day in his big
battle against Ramsay he's ejected
one-on-one come back didn't you I've
reconsidered
he's going after Ramsay at Winterfell
taking his home back taking his life
back and he just please it to a bloody
fricking pop oh yeah so sadly turns his
own hounds on him we realized she's had
one of the best arcs on the show okay
moving on to Michelle would you please
take us beyond the wall poor freakin
Meera has just been dragging bran around
for seasons at this point but we finally
learned what hoe doors name be
frickin bran so it's his fault basically
he was possessing Hodor to hold the door
against the undead army in order to let
him get away talk to us about the
three-eyed Raven he basically tells bran
the time has come you could be Timmy he
dies he lets brand kind of take over the
green seer and gives him this new quest
to go back green fear basically just is
kind of a communing with nature sort of
things he taps into it with trees he is
able to tap into the history of Westeros
he basically is able to time travel and
use the trees as sort of a DeLorean I
mean essentially brand goes back to a
very key moment and bran just learned
that Liana made Ned promise to protect
Jon Liana is actually the mother and
probably Rhaegar Targaryen is the father
and he can influence events in the past
blah blah oh one more thing is that
Benjen Stark came back in a big way cold
hand appeared and for book nerd we were
looking forward to the appearance of
this character and he helped his nephew
brand and mirror to escape and then of
course he was stuck behind the wall but
the question becomes for how long does
benjin come beyond the wall with the
rest of the White Walkers do it I come
as long as it come Spencer um let's go
to your favorite spot on the map King's
Landing oh it's such a lovely system to
really understand King's Landing the
season you have to know that as always
it's all about who controls the throne
whichever being of season six held by
little bold cutted kitten cuddling
Tommen breath yeah and there's three
very powerful factions vying for control
to him one is the Tyrells they have the
daughter Margaery married to Thomas of
she's the queen now team two is as
always Cersei she's got her claws into
her kid she's lost two out of three
children already she's got a
seven-foot-tall zombie bodyguard
and then finally we have this newly
empowered branch of the high Sparrow and
religion has started to play a big part
in King's Landing too with the guns
Cersei has got a trial date coming up
for incest you've got Margaery and Loras
imprisoned and this causes the other two
former rivals the Tyrells and the
Lannisters to join together to put aside
their differences and to take out the
high Sparrow but Tommen comes out and
stops the ruckus from really happening
the crowd and the face together
we will restore the Seven Kingdoms to
glory oh no sir she's defeated or is she
kaput she had wildfire planted under the
great Sept of Baelor blew it all up
everybody dead so long
Tommen sweet little child videos was so
distraught he took a long jump up a high
tower and never to be seen again
Cersei is down three kids up a glass of
wine and up the iron throne which is
what she may wanted all along I now
proclaim says he of the House Lannister
protector of the Seven Kingdoms who
arrives back in King's Landing at that
very moment
Jaime did show up at the end of this
season he kind of went on a detour
before that to break the siege of
Riverrun
so he's really going through this kind
of identity crisis of what his role is
is he a knight who's he holding royalty
- he's still obsessed with Cersei as he
confesses but then you also have big
Brienne of Tarth holding him to a more
chivalrous standard kitchens give little
wispy humans talk to us about
Qyburn and Frank and mountain-high burn
so he's an ex maester gone bad
pumping the mountain last seen dead in
trial by combat full of evil juice
attack I'm an unstoppable killing
machine you get to see a lot of that in
season six and it's awesome
Varys had his little birds but the
little birds are still present little
birds has been interesting it's a term
that Varys used throughout the series
and it's a network of spies made up of
little children who will stab you if you
cross them so Margaery Tyrell is gone
but lady Elena is still around well she
ends the season lining up with Dorne
what is my heart did
fire and blood Michelle we take us to
esos at the beginning of the season you
see Dani being kidnapped by a khalasar
to get brought to Vice do--the rack when
Drogo was killed Dani was supposed to go
there and join the dosh Coleen which is
basically the group of widows
so she gets brought over to vias both
rack and she says I'm not having any of
this and burns them all Yeti but the
reason Tyrion is there with her they
finally got together she made him hand
of the Queen that's where you might
swoop I do decsion assault after kicking
out Dario to the curb saying yeah you're
cute you're great in bed but I'm gonna
need to find me a husband
I can't bring another to lift it beyond
and Yara came from Pike they technically
are royalty
however ironborn choose their next king
and Theon and Yara's uncle Euron comes
back after killing Theon and Yara's
father to take the throne by basically
saying I'm going to let you all rape and
murder and pillage as much as you want
elect me king he eventually wants to get
over to Danny and make some kind of
alliance with her beyond and yard get to
Danny first and make the alliance with
her giving her all of the ships that
they stole from Ironborn won't be enough
to Satan Danny is finally going to
Westeros after six fricken season right
he's going o s throws she has an
unsullied army
she has ships from Yara and Theon she's
finally going with three full-blown
dragons Aria is also on her way home
from Essos she was the girl with no name
she was a flying little girl with no
name who just keeps getting beaten up
until she finally has a showdown with
the weight she becomes no.1 and Jack and
Hakkar says cool you're one of us and
she says no peace I'm going home I'm
already talking to ya the list still
does mean something to her because in
the last episode she goes after Walder
Frey
thing you're ever going to see is a
stock smiling down at you as you die
let's move on to a little speed round
Jorah is he needs to visit the
dermatologist Jorah has the same thing
that Dennis's daughter had he has
greyscale the last thing that happens to
Jorah is he does get exiled by Danny
again saying I come on you to heal
yourself find the cure
Spencer back around you talk to us about
those lovebirds Sam and Gilly they're
still together they got a baby he stole
his dad's sword to be studying to
college and that's the Citadel right
excellent
Ross catch us up on the Hound how did
the character that we loved we thought
was dead he comes back but it's very
quickly he needs up with this guy
brother ray who is he and McShane which
is amazing and this rogue group of
brothers without banners come in and
they kill everyone that the Hound is
connected with taking away is reason to
be a better man now he's out for blood
he goes and he finds the brothers
without banners to get his revenge
they're already gonna kill the roast the
Brotherhood without banners is now
headed to the wall it's possible that
they'll connect with Melisandre on the
way and Sara Kaiser he's been a part of
the things that season one is back boom
and he's going to play the role and
we'll talk about that more on our show
Oh cold winds are rising in the north we
could use you Wow
you guys have done the yeoman's work
you've taken us on a tour of season six
now I want to talk about real quick this
new segment you'll have your introducing
to watching Thrones called raging
throwers first off what exactly is
raging throw nurse if that's the thing
that gets us the most excited about that
episode or in this case the entire
season would each of you give us your
raging thro nur from season six it was
the explosion of the set that whole
sequence that opening sequence to the
finale is so beautifully done so talked
about a method my favorite moment Aria
splitting Walder Frey's throat it's been
a culmination of everything since her
brother and her mother died because her
father died since the list started
finally she gets to cross the big one
off her list I'll say Jon Snow and the
battle ax bastards that one moment where
he runs out and wants to take
the entire army solo come at me bolt on
right here beautiful what a great moment
you know what those are all great raging
throne ORS I can't pick one better than
the next
what's your raging throne er what's
something that we left out or what's
something that you're looking forward to
in season seven of Game of Thrones let
us know in the comments section below we
want to know I want to thank you guys
for coming in and dropping so much
knowledge on us watching Thrones when
can we watch watching Thrones every
Monday screen junkies news 11:00 a.m.
PST live man that is going to be awesome
by the way everybody next week we're
traveling down to San Diego so make sure
you check out screen junkies and screen
junkies news on YouTube for all of our
comic-con coverage presented by t-mobile
America's best unlimited network I want
to thank you for watching screen junkies
I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on Twitter by
like
[Music]